la question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur le ministre plus
vos intentions sur la réforme des
retraites se précise plus elle révèle
des renoncements majeures le dernier en
date concerne les régimes spéciaux alors
que les français demandent la fin des
privilèges aujourd'hui injustifiés de
certains d'entre eux vous proposer à
clause du grand-père pour leur
suppression la situation financière des
retraites est urgente mais vous nous
proposez de légiférer pour dans 40 ans
c'est plutôt la clause du petit-fils
voire de l'arrière petit-fils monsieur
le ministre vous vous féliciter que le
climat des négociations avec les
syndicats soient bons mais quand on
connaît le conservatisme de certains
d'entre eux ce n'est pas un bon signe
pour votre réforme à l'heure où le
gouvernement nous parle de
l'acceptabilité il serait bon que
l'acceptabilité de cette réforme soit
celle des Français l'acceptabilité c'est
que chacun fasse un effort oui un effort
et pas uniquement le secteur privé
au contraire votre réforme qui prétend
unifier les régimes oppose en réalité
les fonctionnaires les salariés du privé
laissent de côté les régimes spéciaux
monsieur le ministre la situation des
finances sociales et la sauvegarde de
notre modèle pour les Français exigent
du courage et de l'équité le courage
serait d'assurer une hausse de l'âge de
départ pour tous comme le groupe les
républicains le demandent depuis des
années comme tous nos grands pays
voisins et partenaires européens l'ont
fait et comme les Français sont prêts à
l'accepter travailler plus longtemps
alors que notre espérance de vie nous le
permet c'est non seulement préserver le
système de retraite mais aussi dégagé
les moyens de relever le minimum
retraite au-delà de 1100 euros comme
vous le prétendez vous avez abandonné
l'idée d'un système universel et avec
lui l'idée d'un système équitable
l'équité serait que pour des métiers
comparables les fonctionnaires les
salariés les bénéficiaires des régimes
spéciaux et des conditions de retraite
comparable ma donc simple combien de
milliards d'euros et de dettes
supplémentaires